Fox News propagandist Sean Hannity is trying to
push Donald Trump even further on these corrupt
pardons. We know that Donald Trump is already
considering preemptively blanket pardoning
his attorney, Rudy Giuliani. He's considering
preemptive pardons for his son in law, Jared
Kushner. And three of his children, Ivanka, Don
Jr. and Eric, but Rudy Giuliani on his radio show
this week I'm sorry, Sean Hannity on his radio
show this week, suggested that Donald Trump should
really pardon himself as well, because everybody
is just so unfair and terrible to Trump and they
might go after him when he's out of office. Take
a listen. This is actually from an interview
that Sean Hannity does with Sidney Powell. And
it's fascinating that even Sidney Powell, who's
completely deranged, has to say, you know, self
pardon's. I'm not so sure about that. Take a look.
Unfortunately, I'd estimate that five to 10
percent of our prison population right now is not
guilty, but the system did not work as
it should have to exonerate them. And
we've got to do a better job of that. Not
everybody can get a presidential pardon.
Well, that's a good point. And, you
know, I watched Andrew Weissman come
out and literally say, oh, Biden's
AG needs to go after Donald Trump.
And I'm like, the president out the door, needs
to pardon his whole family and himself because
they want this witch hunt to go on
in perpetuity is so full of rage and
insanity against the president. I mean, it's the
president. I assume that the power of the pardon
is absolute and that he should be able
to pardon anybody that he wants to.
It is absolute. It's in the Constitution. I
don't know about his authority to pardon himself,
but it should not be necessary. And aside from
that, the president is going to get another four
years in office to finish the job he started
because the election fraud we are uncovering
is massive. And there were foreign actors
involved in our system that's actually
really funny, even completely delusional.
Deranged attorney Sidney Powell has to mention,
you know, Sean, I'm just not totally sure about
Trump's ability to pardon himself. And that's
actually an important detail. Now, Sydney Powell
is saying lots of crazy things here. So is Sean
Hannity. Powell saying Trump actually won. Powell
saying Trump's going to get another four years.
But she does mention Trump pardoning himself is a
question mark. And The New York Times had a really
good write up on this issue. Remember that Donald
Trump has claimed that he can pardon himself. He
tweeted back in June of twenty eighteen, which
seems like a decade ago, quote, As has been stated
by numerous legal scholars, I have the absolute
right to pardon myself, but why would I do that
when I have done nothing wrong? In the meantime,
the never ending witch hunt, led by 13 very
angry and conflicted Democrats, continues into the
midterms. Trump can pardon his friends and allies.
There's no doubt about it. Trump can pardon people
before they are even charged. A preemptive pardon
is certainly something Trump can do. Trump cannot
protect people from state charges. It is very much
in question, however, whether a president can
pardon himself or herself. And it's never been
attempted. Now, there are legal opinions on both
sides. On the yes side, a president can pardon
themselves. The argument is the Constitution
doesn't say anything about a limit there. The
Constitution says nothing about you can't pardon
yourself. The Constitution does say if you if a
president is impeached and convicted, they can't
pardon themselves from an impeachment conviction.
So the interpretation from some legal scholars
is, listen, it's very clear that when there was
meant to be a limit, the Constitution mentions
the limit. The Constitution mentions a president
can't pardon themselves from an impeachment
conviction. So we can infer from that that if
the founders intended a president would be unable
to pardon themselves from federal crimes, it would
be mentioned since it's not mentioned a president
can do it. That's one interpretation. OK, now
on the other side, there are many counters. One
counter is the Constitution says the president can
grant a pardon. And this is a sort of linguistic
analysis the word grant means from the president
to someone else. And so the presence of the word
grant means a president can't pardon themselves.
That's one argument, another argument on the the
president can't pardon themselves side argues that
a principle in all law, nationally, federally,
at the state level, there's a principle in law
that you cannot be a judge in your own case
and that a self pardon would effectively be the
president being a judge in his or her own case.
So the simplest situation, as has been discussed,
is instead of Trump pardoning himself and maybe
being subject to legal challenge, the simplest
path forward that has been floated is Trump
resigns shortly before the end of his term.
Mike Pence becomes president. Mike Pence
pardons Donald Trump. No doubt about it.
That would be far simpler. I still don't think
that that is actually going to happen. But it
would be interesting to be wrong on that one,
and if it if I am wrong and Donald Trump does
resign in order for Mike Pence to preemptively
pardon him, that will be one of the biggest
political history stories, certainly for decades
to come. Later on today, we are going to talk
about international reaction to the continued
voter fraud claims being made in the United States
and international reaction to Joe Biden continuing
to move forward with his incoming administration.
We are also going to talk I got a lot of emails
from people saying, David, do you think Tucker
Carlson is the direction the Republican Party will
go in in 2024? And I have some thoughts about it,
which we will discuss a little bit later. And
then we also now that the presidential transition
has formally been started, the GSA saying we are
releasing these seven point three million dollars
in funds to Joe Biden to officially start
that transition. We are going to address
the question of whether presidential transitions
should even depend on a sitting president. But
there's a second layer to that question, which
is, do they really even depend on the sitting
president? Because remember whether or not the
transition funds were released to Joe Biden.
Donald Trump stops being president on January 20th
at noon Eastern Time either way. So all of those
questions and your calls are upcoming. We've got
a great program for you today. Let me know what
you're following, what you're paying attention to.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman. We
will take a very quick break
and be back right after this.